bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour décrypter
l'actualité
notre dossier du jour est consacré au
malaise des personnels hospitaliers par
le rose aussi des débats télévisés aux
états unis quel est leur poids dans la
course à la maison blanche thomas
snégaroff est notre invité vous regardez
l'inattendu et vous êtes les bienvenus
madame monsieur bonsoir je voudrais
regarder la franche au fond des yeux
sinon je serais beaucoup que les uns
apprennent à tricoter d'accord là-dessus
à votre place je la ramène un peu moins
mais si vous ne réussissez pas ce qu'il
vous manque qu'une seule chose un tout
petit détail le confédéralisme à paris
de ce qui lui arrive à la bleue à mes
côtés ludivine lopez et tariq ali
journaliste à la rédaction dina bonjour
à tous les deux vous avez décortiquer
les grands titres de la presse cette
semaine
ces deux sujets ont plus
particulièrement retenu votre attention
ludivine vous c'est le malaise des
infirmiers ya malaise qui s'est
accentuée ces derniers mois avec la
crise du coc vide si près de 40 % des
infirmiers envisage carrément de changer
de métier 57% estiment être en burn-out
d'après une étude de l'ordre des
infirmiers cette réalité et est déjà
décrite dans le passé écouter cette
infirmière en 1966
selon les statistiques une infirmière
sur trois abandonne son métier moins de
dix ans après l'obtention de son diplôme
pourquoi avez vous abandonné le travail
dans les hôpitaux parce que vraiment
c'est absolument incompatible avec une
vie normale et le travail est absolument
épuisant les horaires chanson très
mauvais
c'est absolument septimanie j'étais
complètement épuisé quoi et d'autre part
le salaire aussi n'est pas du tout en
conséquence avec le travail les
responsabilités le malaise des soignants
on y reviendra avec vous tout à l'heure
ludivine dans notre dossier du jour
alors vous tarik gourmand que vous êtes
vous nous parler de la semaine du goût
et pourquoi parce que je suis gourmand
un plaisir et aussi parce que cette
semaine du goût bell est un peu
particulière avec le co vide puisque
justement la perte de goût est l'un des
symptômes un duc au vide alors pour vous
réveiller les papilles je vous ai trouvé
une petite recette pleine de serveurs du
terroir il s'agit d'un burger préparé
par maïté on regarde en 92 j'ai fait
revenir vos foies gras mais malgré les
jets 10 avant qu'on aille bien installé
sur la jolie salle ar alors
le faire parce que c'est bon ça nourrit
et un jour dessus voilà on va dire que
ce soit en nourrice alors oui ça c'est
pas mauvais voilà un bon là et ont
découvert que par là dessus non ça vous
donner aux petits déjeuners à pierrot
tous les jours voilà bien sûr bon
appétit si vous êtes à table alors ça
c'était pour l'actualité des derniers
jours mais sinon que s'est-il passé le
14 octobre
ces dernières années c'est le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé
un 14 octobre regardez c'est le révérend
martin luther king à qui vient d'être
attribué le prix nobel de la paix pour
1964 écouter la déclaration qu'il eut
l'occasion de faire il ya quelques temps
à l'un de nos collaborateurs
je suis grande seule ville hans nous
gagnerons l'égalité raciale
célibataire sans enfants complètement
inexpérimentés en politique ne redonne
sihamoni était jusque là surtout connu
pour ses talents de danseur c'est là que
40000 parisien massés sur le boulevard
devait rendre un dernier hommage à edith
piaf et la foule se taisaient encore
tandis que le cortège dirigés à pied
vers la sépulture la foule shopping
au passage du premier cercueil celui
lütschine il ya ni fleurs ni cris
seulement le silence le président
mitterrand a coupé le ruban
on peut donc se promener désormais
autour de la partie je dirais immergez
vous la voyez la partie immergée de la
pyramide dans quelques secondes il va
accomplir sous vos yeux un exploit
descend les 210 mètres de la tour
montparnasse encore plus vite qu'il est
monté c'est parti cet autrichien réalise
un pari fou être le premier homme à
franchir le mur du son que ce soit super
sonic et le plus haut du monde quatre
fois plus haut que l'everest
attention ce genre de pouey ce n'est pas
permis à tout le monde
franck à 300 sont derrière lui en plus
c'est interdit ne suffit pas de sauter
il faut au sol
il faut aussi savoir courir bonsoir et à
denain
très soignons de nouveau dans la rue
journée de mobilisation cette semaine
deux journées de grève à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats hospitaliers parmi
les revendications le manque de lits
dans les établissements publics
une situation dénoncée depuis longtemps
ludivine wii est le point de départ
c'est la réforme hospitalière de 1979
pour faire des économies le gouvernement
va s'immiscer dans l'hôpital public
la loi autorise désormais le ministre de
la santé a fermé des services des délits
la réduction des dépenses fait donc
désormais partie des préoccupations des
directeurs d'établissements en 1980
certains étaient particulièrement
inquiets et dénoncer déjà la notion
d'hôpital entreprises regardez l'hôpital
public que se trouve dans la même
situation que les entreprises privées
c'est à dire qui lui appartient dans la
crise économique de poser les mêmes
questions de l'entreprise privée mais je
dirais attention les économies ont une
limite en dessous d'un certain seuil il
ne serait plus possible de soigner
convenablement les malades on a des
économies qui se traduisent par des
fermetures de lits les années suivantes
ça ne va pas plaire aux soignants dès
les années 90 les réformes de santé se
succèdent et avec elle les
manifestations et les grèves
regardez ici nous sommes en 1993 à
orléans le personnel soignant étaient
mobilisés contre la suppression des lits
et des la réduction des effectifs
regarder ton ferme de service évidemment
que c'est grave parce que ça bloque
l'activité
on sait plus où mettre les malades c'est
pas normal un hobby d'aller bouffer pour
fermer et les faits pour soigner dans
les années 2000 le message est répétée
de manifestations en blocage au point
qu'à l'hiver 2002 nous sommes en pleine
épidémie de grippe
le célèbre médecin urgentiste patrick
peloux lance un appel à l'aide
là nous sommes dans une situation qui
est absolument dantesque puisqu'il n'y a
plus de lits pour pouvoir hospitalisés
les malades venant aux urgences et que
nous avons connu ces jours ci même
et soirée où il n'y avait pas de lits de
réanimation si je peux me permettre le
deal à ce que dit patrick peloux c'était
en 2002 ok 18 ans exactement la même
chose aujourd'hui on fait tout à fait et
malgré ses cris d' alerte il ya 18 ans
vous l'avez dit tariq les fermetures de
lits ont continué la drees le service de
statistiques du ministère de la santé le
révélait l'année dernière dans un
rapport
regardez ce graphique entre 2003 et 2010
est le nombre de lits en hospitalisation
complète est passé de 460 8418 à 399
1865 soit plus de 68 1500 fermetures en
14 ans alors autre statistique à prendre
en compte quand même
l'hospitalisation ambulatoire tout est
fait pour que les malades ne dorment
plus à l'hôpital
c'est vrai qu'à partir des années 90
avec 90 la france à prendre le virage de
l'hospitalisation ambulatoire des
séjours de moins d'une journée on parle
alors de places en hospitalisation
partielle et quand on regarde les
chiffres encore une fois toujours sur la
période 2003 2010 est le nombre de lits
en hospitalisation partielle a bien
augmenté + 26 1089 place n'est pas de
quoi compenser lesquels que 69 mille
places perdues en hospitalisation
complète
écoutez d'ailleurs cet ophtalmologiste
en 2003 la chirurgie ambulatoire était
sa bête noire
j'ai expérimenté personnellement
récemment la chirurgie ambulatoire
j'ai pas l'âge de mes malades mais c'est
une horreur
je les ai pas bien vous dit s'il
m'arrive un pépin je vais ou qu'est ce
que je fais et pourtant bon je suis
médecin mais je suis mais mon dieu je
fais quoi là
j'appelle qui sait le système médical
français qui était numéro un et on est
en train de le bazar des deux le bousier
ça me fait mal au coeur
vraiment mal au coeur je bloquais le
réseau pour des raisons soit disant
économique
alors on l'a vu un le manque de lits
dans les hôpitaux publics est l'un des
indicateurs du malaise hospitalier il
s'accompagne d'un élargissement des
horaires de réduction du personnel et
donc d'épuisement professionnel un mal
être qui est très souvent dénoncée dans
la rue voilà la colère des soignants
insu
j'ai dont on reparlera forcément dans
les prochaines semaines les prochaines
mois les prochains mois lopez merci à
vous pour ses explications
[Musique]
c'est l'un des sujets qui animent la
campagne présidentielle aux états unis
l'annulation cette semaine et pour des
raisons sanitaires du seul débat qui
offrait tous les électeurs la
possibilité d'interroger les candidats
certains y voient une esquive de donald
trump pour ne pas répondre de son bilan
alors quelle poisse et des bas ont-ils
dans la course à la maison blanche pour
en parler nous accueillons un historien
passionné d'amérique
d'archives/reuters/thomas snégaroff
alors pour commencer j'aimerais vous
faire réagir à cet extrait du débat
précédent entre trump hebeisen c'était
le 27 29 septembre dernier regarder à
peine le débat lancé le candidat
démocrate je baille des attaques donald
c'est un an
s'ensuivent des échanges houleux au
milieu de la cacophonie de parler avec
ce cône voilà vous allez la ferme et
c'est vraiment le pire des bas de
l'histoire comme l'ont dit certains
observateurs
je crois qu'il ya un mot qui est en trop
dans ce que vous dites ces débats en
fait il ya pas eu de débat pour qu'il ya
un débat il faut qu'on s'entende autour
de thèmes communs qu'on soit d'accord
autour d'une réalité commune autour de
laquelle on débat là ont tous les deux
là on est en train de demander même s'il
ya un débat on est on ya un échange en
bas la garenne échange entre nous sur
des termes qu'on accepte tous les deux
là s'étaient même pas le cas c'est que
chacun était dans son tunnel
voulant couper l'autre traitant on l'a
vu bayonne prétend l'aude menteur mais
inversement appartement où on n'est même
pas d'accord sur la même réalité on peut
plus débattre peut plus discuter et du
coup le nom même de débat se pose alors
dire c'est le débat le pire de
l'histoire américaine
peut-être mais c'est peut-être aussi la
première fois qu' il n'y a pas un débat
lors d'une présidentielle américaine
depuis 1960 parce que premier débat on
va reparler peut-être c'est kennedy
nixon en soixante eh bien je vous prends
au mot justement le tout deux baies
premier débat remonte à 1960 c'était la
première fois la télé en même temps à la
radio à regret la première fois qu'on
voit deux candidats sur le même plateau
vous l'avez dit kennedy et nixon et pour
animer ce débat un modérateur a comme
aujourd'hui et quatre journalistes alors
je vous
on va voir un extrait c'est beaucoup
plus mou ça n'a absolument rien à voir
avec ce qu'on vient de voir
et malgré tout à l'époque il y avait
quand même entre 60 et 70 millions de
téléspectateurs c'est pas ça on regarde
tout de suite
donc là on voit un kennedy qui crève
l'écran qui est préparée à l'exercice et
à côté un nixon un peu plus raide un peu
plus sévère est ce que la télé à ce
moment là en 1960 elle change quelque
chose dans la campagne présidentielle
oui dans la mesure où quand on demande
aux américains de l'époque qui a gagné
le débat
vous avez des réponses différentes entre
ceux qui regardent la télé ce qu'ils
écoutent la radio
les gens qui écoutent la radio se disent
c'est plutôt nixon qui a été bons parce
qu'il a réussi à dérouler son programme
les gens qui regardent la télé on vient
de le voir eux disent le vainqueur n'y a
pas de doute c'est kennedy parce que
vous dites vous montrer c'est tellement
il est il est maquillée d'abord la
washington n'est pas maquillée
c'est un petit piège de kennedy qui
avait sa propre maquilleuse nixon arrive
à 10 mais est-ce qu'on est maquillé les
productions le liban n'y a pas de mcr
prévu je ne serai pas maquillée comme
kennedy sauf que kennedy a sa propre
maquilleuse qui le maquis et du coup il
y en a un qui a mauvaise mine
l'autre qui éclate vous dites d'ailleurs
plus auditoire il ya la jeunesse de
kennedy mais ils ont le même âge sauf
qu'on a l'impression avec l'un avec sa
barbe qui pousse de 10 de 17 heures il
ya vraiment un décalage d'image et
l'image elle est du côté de kennedy qui
en plus dans l'extrait que vous avez
montré sur le fond la substance peut
apparaître comme celui qui met
l'amérique en mouvement donc en jeunesse
et son image elles cadrent avec son
discours mais est-ce que vous parler
d'imagés ce que la forme avait à
l'époque en tout cas plus d'importance
que le fond alors c'est difficile à dire
le fond et la forme ont toujours été
comme ça et victor hugo la forme c'est
le fond à la surface
les deux ont toujours fonctionné
ensemble et ça marche quand vous avez le
fond et la forme
ensemble et la kennedy ça marche parce
qu'il ya le fond et la forme ensemble le
fond c'est un programme qui
l'amérique en mouvement la forme c'est
la jeunesse c'est difficile de proposer
une amérique en mouvement quand vous
êtes très vieux c'est pour ça que trump
aujourd'hui 10 de belledonne qu'il est
endormi ça permet de dire vous croyez
que ce type endormi au va ramener
l'amérique dans en mouvement non et
c'est aussi pour ça il ya un enjeu très
fort autour de la virilité et la santé
de donald trump
alors là on est en 1960 puis plus de
débats jusqu'en 1976 ce retour tariq est
marquée par le premier couac la première
gaffe de campagne à la tête la première
gaffe qu'on doit à dire halte fort d'un
président sortant dans un contexte de
guerre froide écoutez bien ce qu'il
disait à l'époque une golf comme ça
thomas snégaroff à la télé en direct
aucune chance qu'elle ne passe inaperçu
tant il ya l'effet loupe de la télé on
serait tenté de dire carrément que cette
gaffe
elle a contribué à la défaite mais la
gare elle marche d'autant plus qu'elles
cadrent avec la personne qui fait la
gaffe si vous avez quelqu'un c'est un
lapsus on va dire bon c'est pas grave ça
passe mais là le problème c'est que
gerald ford
il a un double handicap quand il arrive
à ce débat il n'a jamais été élu
président des états unis puisqu'il a
remplacé nixon démissionnaire et il
n'était même pas le vice-président sur
le colisée
il est des matins vice-président de nick
172 il avait remplacé un vice-président
spiro agnew qui lui-même avait
démissionné donc il était même pas il a
jamais été sur un ticket président
il ya donc pour les américains il ya un
vent d'illégitimité et puis il est connu
pour ses gaffes johnson le président
johnson disait de lui qu'il était
incapable de mâcher un chewing gum et le
marché en même temps oui c'est un bon
c'est pas facile pour certains pour lui
en tout cas ça monde ou bien que je me
trouvais au football américain et un
côté un peu il est un peu débile alors
c'est pas vrai bien sûr mais quand vous
avez ça dans la tête des américains
et puis le président dise ah décidément
et clairement il n'est pas président des
états unis qu'à une gaffe à les limites
pendant un discours là on est en direct
via le modérateur et c'est le rôle du
modérateur qui l'a vraiment ne rate pas
qu on a vu souvent des gaffes comme ça
dans les campagnes américaines avec
d'autres présidents non c'est assez rare
en fait c'est assez rare mais la cm à
c'est est ce que c'est une gaffe en fait
je pense et il était une erreur sans
garde fou c'est une erreur non en fait
il veut tellement en fait il veut
tellement montrer que sous son
administration se son pouvoir
l'amérique elle est puissante c est que
avec force et avec carter sera une
catastrophe qui on arrive à dire des
choses pareilles donc non mais je crois
que des gaffes de ce type là honnêtement
dans ma mémoire j'en vois pas de telle
nature et c'est vrai que ça a été
catastrophique pour lui qui prend une
vraie raclée contre contre eux en tout
cas pas tout-à-fait l'échelle des gaffes
mais plutôt des maladresses ont là aussi
ces images de bush père qui regarde sa
montre qui s'est engagée maladresse week
end message très positif en vols d'essai
tout simplement
il ya eu d'autres d'autres situations
un petit peu embarrassante a comme ça ta
ricains d'autres situations mais avec
certains qui s'en sortent beaucoup mieux
avec un petit peu d'habileté et d'humour
c'est le cas de ronald reagan en 1984
son principal défaut en tout cas on l'
attaque pendant la campagne sur son âge
et regarder comment il s'en sort vous
devez savoir que je ne serai pas de la
jeanne éléments de cette campagne mais
je ne suis pas disposé à exploiter pour
des vues politiques la jeunesse et le
manque d'expérience de mon adversaire
là derrière sur le plateau d'arrêt les
écrans aussi est-ce que à ça ce type de
comportement les américains y sont
sensibles
et ça marche vous rappeler que c'est le
deuxième débat entre mme ndèye et
reggane et le premier but a été
catastrophique pour reggane et c'est
l'âge de regan qui pose un problème on
dit mais il est plus à la page il est
incapable il répond pas c'est qu'il a
l'air
vraiment à côté pendant le premier des
bandes il est endormi un peu comme un
bug jeunes d'aujourd'hui
et donc ils trouvent la parade c'est pas
une question c'est évidemment préparé
énormément préparé il sait qu'on va lui
parler de l'âge c'est le modérateur
qu'il en parle c'est pas walter mondale
et ça marche énormément même wendel se
marre
son adversaire se marre et ça marche
parce que l'humour c'est une valeur
extraordinairement forte aux états unis
c'est que nous ont habitués à nos débats
présidentiels
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'humour c'est
plutôt de petites phrases des piques
on est un peu de la répartie et de la
répartie c'est peut-être une tradition
française aussi la de la répartie
effectivement de la phrase bien sentie
de mai s'est jamais un humour qui fait
rire tout le monde
là c'est en public en plus donc regan
arrive à retourner la situation montré
que l'âge n'est pas un problème c'est un
élément de son expérience politique et
du coup ils renvoient mandel assez cher
et c'est presque un show finalement
organisé ou un présenter ou en tout cas
dont ronald regan et et le est le héros
que reste-t-il du fond d'un discours
comme celui là portée par parts égales
de ce débat là ouais bah il reste pas
grand chose en fait il reste qu'on vient
de voir certains on se souvient de cette
phrase oui voilà derrière alors il faut
savoir qu'il avait quand même plus de
vingt points d'avancé dans les sondages
donc c'était pas pour le sauver du tout
hein c'était sa voix la sas a conforté
des américains dans l'idée que c'est un
bon président qui allait faire un
deuxième mandat il a été réélu de
manière magistrale
c'est pas c'est pas un des éléments
c'est pas un décès pas comme gerald ford
et sa gamme c'est pas un des moments où
ça a basculé
ou comme le maquillage de kennedy là on
est plutôt sur un une pépite d'archivés
comme on aime à l'ina est comme moi
j'aime beaucoup aussi
mais qui n'a pas changé définitivement
la vie politique américaine saric depuis
les années 80 l'audience de des débats
stagner autour des 40 millions de
téléspectateurs 2016 record 84 millions
d'américains devant leur poste qu'est ce
qui s'est passé il s'est passé que
donald trump est arrivé sur la scène
politique et forcément on a envie de
voir à quoi ça ressemble donc là c'est
plus vraiment un déboulé sur des piques
ans qu'on faisait tout à l'heure on
regarde ça tout de suite une petite
sélection
elle n'a pas le look elle n'a pas
l'endurance qu'elle pourrait être
président de ce pays il faut une
sérieuse endurance donald était pour
l'intervention en irak
c
s c'est prouvé on regarde ça comme un
match de boxe en fait c'est vraiment ça
et d'ailleurs quand on dit que baydan
tron s'était pas un débat celui-là
c'était pas non plus un grand débat et
il faut savoir un peu s'il y avait des
images d'un autre débat outre homme se
promène et s'approche même physiquement
de deux d'hillary clinton on a déjà
aussi dans un autre débat
c'était avec george bush et al gore en
2000 vous avez al gore qui s'approche de
george bush mais de manière quasiment
quasiment inquiétante et george bush je
le regarde étonné enfin il ya des
moments comme ça c'est vraiment une
scénographie où les américains voient
deux corps en face d'eux et c'est la
première fois qu'on les voit ensemble il
faut une campagne très longue en chacun
dans son coin et huayi son ensemble et
quand on voit trump parler de
l'endurance et du corps il sait que les
américains ont besoin à ce moment là en
2016 d'un choc de testostérone quoi et
surtout il a un appel à un électorat qui
aime bien ça et donc ils insistent
là-dessus parce qu'il sait qu'ils sont
côte à côte c'est bien beau de l'iran
meeting mais là elle d'y regarder à
l'apa le look il la regarde elle est pas
capable et donc c'est pour ça que ces
débats là soit aussi important et c'est
aussi pour cela que trump à mon avis a
refusé le débat virtuel qu'on lui
proposait pour cette semaine là le débat
virtuel et l'a refusée parce que je
pense qu'il a bien compris que son atout
c'était un atout de corps à corps avec
joe biden voilà les débats télévisés
dans la campagne américaine vue par
thomas snégaroff merci mille fois j'y
retourne à pour pour cet éclairage voilà
comme chaque semaine on termine cette
inattendue avec une petite pépite de
l'ina alors à quelques jours de l'été 80
cabu chante une chanson de charles
trenet débit de l'eau débit de lait et
c'était dans une émission qui vous a
certainement marqué vous aussi thomas
deux pistolets
à quel débit
baby doll est si haut débit de l'eau
tiède s'il est un beau défi
c'est bien beau debitel et les badauds
sont emballés par les bidons de lait de
bébé
les mobiles
garde pour lui et du pup hôpitaux de
l'ap et jolie et maintenant si vous y
allez l'entendre et de joyeux ma ville
mon bébé blanc toujours nommés
tous les bidons d'être la maison voilà
pour cabu et récré a2 euro se retrouvent
mercredi prochain à 21h sur le canal 27
août la semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
de france info uddin à 1 édition
préparée bien sûr avec les
documentalistes documentaliste de l'ina
magali vernon et le honor prévaut quand
lieu merci à elle pour ceux travaillant
nuit là à bientôt
[Musique]